não dá pra resistir não vilão vôo ou
você minha é assim
baby uhuuu teus meses são pra mim e
tensa tom e aí olha que meu canal com
vocês nesse dia 12 agora hoje pelo caso
no caso hoje é 11 porque eu tô gravando
um dia antes é o dia dos namorados no
dia 12 dia dos namorados diz aquele que
todo mundo fica feliz se abraçando e não
diz namorada muito tempo eu acho que
deixou de ser uma hora época em que ia
todo mundo chamar a filha rosa que na
manhã de hoje e deixou que segundo ele
desde que o namoro de hoje deixou de ser
aquela coisa amorosa que era um amor de
hoje não é aquela coisa calorosa e
amorosa que era desligado seu mini na
casa do pai se mijando papicú pedia no
namoro do pai pessoal um livro muito por
amor ele tem mais é o estado
ele já deslandes
eu queria fazer o que eu estava no ninho
do urubu leite e eu acho esse assunto
não diga
nesse dia tão especial você quer namorar
comigo é muito importante na minha vida
e também não chamou o status do facebook
hoje olha por mim eu mudar mais ainda a
china então vai tomar no seu cuca
namorar só se formou no facebook eu falo
farinha é uma pena uma coisa acho
engraçado namoro é que a pessoa ela no
caje no meio dos amigos do gt lage
conversando com a namorada o bebê
revelar o teor do voto do bom-nome
montas haddad você também tava com
saudade
do meu gol com saudade quero ver você
ora com isso bem eu também quero te ver
beber a israel e nem quer peitinho que é
com um tag isso quer eu pintei o cabelo
tá bonita tem pinta o cabelo de kikut
verde lei foi melhor ainda de cabelo
bonito parece coringa ai que coisa mais
fofa ea naval alada feito tratamento que
o tal de ficou pensando para toda a
capital viveu na oi oi bebê está com
quem ia pouco ao toque com bryan que
horas você vai pra casa vem agora chega
ou chegar perto ou seja já que você está
fazendo aí não temos só que conversou
mesmo disparada por vê lo para casa viu
tá bom arranque nova eu te amo bb espera
ainda boa também te amo muito também viu
bom o bb diz que mesmo vai esquecer me
ama vai de mãe muitas namoradas muito
estranho até tinha namorada dez horas da
noite bem tinham que fazer dessa noite
ela dormia já é à toa dormir
domingo eu tive outra namorada que não
gostava de nada que eu gostava eu
gostava de sair ela não gostava eu
gostava de assistir filme ela não
gostava do estado de lasanha pizza não
gostava não gostava de nada e por isso
terminou já teve outra namorada que a
gente terminou porque ela gostava
também de tudo que eu gostava eu gostava
de filme ela também eu gostava de
animais ela também eu gostava de mim e
ela também
acho engraçado que a mãe da gente quer
falar nada e nunca é muito novo pra
namorar é muito novo pra namorar você
pergunta conhece até o primeiro filho
com quantos anos que ele a gente falar e
aluno que o dia dos namorados nada no
dia dos namorados
sim mas eu curta eu quero anunciar um
crachá no apartamento a quitinete reta
mas é isso aí o vídeo e conheça não
tinha nada preparado de namorar só tenho
que deixar passar em branco
se você gostou desse vídeo você já sabe
o que fazer é clicar aqui e gostei se
você tiver no facebook você compartilha
esse vídeo se você está aqui no youtube
você clica aqui e gostei comenta aqui
embaixo no facebook e no youtube tem que
ser mais odeia no dia dos namorados e
clique em inscrever-se para toda vez que
tiver de novo você receber e sabe que o
time de novo ea isso aí coisa e tal
passa pela e feliz dia dos namorados